for more than half of my life Scotland
has been governed by parties that we
didn't elect at Westminster and these
parties have given us from everything
from the the poll tax to the bedroom tax
and they are the same people who through
project fear of telling us that this
country can't run our own affairs my
case this evening is simple no one
absolutely no one will do a better job
of running Scotland the people who live
and work in Scotland on the 18th of
September we have the opportunity of a
lifetime we should seize it with both
hands
all of us who live here are proud of
Scotland of course we are I won't
Scotland to prosper we all do but it is
not our patriotism that is at stake
tonight rather it's something bigger
than that and that's the future of our
country the future for our children and
our grandchildren and it isn't just for
politicians it's for all of us and you
know there are times that for the love
of our family and the love of our
country it's sometimes best to say no
not because we can't but simply because
it is not the best thing to do now in
six weeks time we will make the biggest
decision that we've ever made here in
Scotland and remember this if we decide
to leave there is no going back there's
no second chance one thing we can say
with absolute certainty when Scotland
comes becomes independent then an every
single election will get the government
that Scotland votes for we can say that
with absolute certainty every time
Scotland goes into a general election we
have the risk of having people we didn't
vote for ruling over us when it comes to
voting government getting government she
didn't vote for I didn't vote for him
I'm stuck with him I just extend that's
what happens
in person or boat we've had this
declaration today from the leaders of
the UK parties there will definitely be
more powers occurring to Scotland
give me two powers that will definitely
accrue both tax and increased power over
which is in bends over income tax all of
it
income tax the power to power - there's
two things happening there is power
already coming - to vary the rate of
income tax so yes there are substantial
powers responsibilities over nearly 40%
of what the Scottish government spends
and I think that is a major step forward
but as I say it maintains the fact we
have a Scottish Parliament but we also
have the advantage of the opportunities
and securities that come from being part
of the United Kingdom and we don't take
on a whole bunch of risks a currency
union only works if you've got a
political union which is what we've got
today
now look any eight-year-old can tell you
the flag of the country the capital of a
country and its currency and I presume
the flags the sort are I assume our
capital will still be Edinburgh but you
can't tell us what currency will have
we'll keep the phone because it belongs
to Scotland as much as it belongs to
England
it's our pound as well as your phone
even Gordon Brown has said that the
George Osborne coming up to Scotland is
saying you shall not have other phone
doctor for your campaign so why can't we
go back to the alistair darling of last
year saying it was logical and desirable
and interests of scotland and in the
interests of the rest of united kingdom
to keep the pound
after independence logical undesirable
with this this this reminds me of when
you said you had legal advice that said
we'd automatically get back into the
european union and it didn't exist
you're not doing yourself any favours
let's see if we can go at it through a
process of elimination
earlier this year on the television you
said you had a range of options if you
didn't get the currency union when you
were pressed about it you said your
options B C D and E what is option B
please tell us and I pointed out and
that interview we have a fiscal
commission report which in page four
sets out a range of options for Scotland
I'm sure you've read it the fiscal
commission has a range of prominent
economists a couple of Nobel laureates
but I want what's best for Scotland
what's best for Scotland is keeping the
pound sterling we should kill the global
famine early because it's good for
scholars of the United Kingdom both of
us want the country University and the
European Union it's not important that
we discuss actually the practicalities
of it it is quite clear that Scotland
would have to reapply it is not at all
clear what the terms and conditions are
they would have to meet I know from my
experience of negotiating in the
European Union even when everybody's
agreed any one of the 28 member states
can veto anything they want and it
doesn't have to be about Scotland and we
ought to be discussing these issue one
because they are critical to start with
there
never mind about websites and can
doesn't done as we both want to be in
the European Union then why as your ally
in the campaign the foreign sector who
says your vote to take the UK out of the
European Union
why are you allies in the no campaign
saying that even your partner in the no
campaign
David Cameron has said supporters of
independence will always be able to cite
examples of small independent thriving
economies across Europe it would be
wrong to suggest starting could be not
be another such successful independent
country do you agree with David Cameron
on that but this more Grievous of all
countries you have to make sure they
balance the books in figures in your own
figures we have would have a much bigger
deficit at the time you want
independence than the rest of the UK and
that would mean some very difficult
decisions quite we do a lot prepared to
face you agree with mr. sauna
do you agree with David Cameron was just
going to make another point on who you
agree with David Cameron or not
let me ask you a question - the answer
as the other point about small countries
making of the weekend is we do look at
the pressures we face our bending I
think the risks of Independence frankly
not worth mr. Sammon I feel arrest yeah
I feel like Jeremy fights with Michael
how appear do you agree with David
Cameron or not well you're more like
Michael Howard if you're going to enter
into a currency union two sets of people
the rest of the UK and Scotland would
have to agree the terms and conditions
of a currency union and one of the
things you'll be asking the rest of the
UK to do is to underwrite a Scottish
banking system that is twelve times the
size of Scotland's wealth in Cyprus it
was only eight times as large and all
I'm saying to you is that there's no law
no Constitution no sovereignty compelled
to people to say why but the figure of a
just there is just cited as a treasury
figure which assumed all the capital
assets of the Royal Bank of Scotland the
markets division that are allocated to
Scotland not a single person in that
group what's in Scotland did in the
markets division of the Royal Bank of
Scotland
they've never what anyone else but
London that is why the Royal Bank of
Scotland has more employees in London
than it does in Scotland that's why if
listen Alistair it's not a great point
to me because you were in charge of
financial regulation when the banks went
bust that is the point
of course I was the Chancellor of the
Exchequer I have responsibility for
every single thing I did during the time
I was Chancellor including stopping the
banking system from collapsing partly
contribute to austerity of course we'll
you had a banking crisis there not a
state it then led to an economic crisis
and any government no matter how large
how small would have left would have to
deal with that it's Scotland have been
independent to say at the time it would
have been exactly the same position as
Ireland and Iceland remember the arc of
prosperity both of those countries are
bust now because they could be deal with
the bad guys oil is a great thing since
you asked earlier it's been a great boon
base all our what you kill our prospects
on a declining source of income and to
make every single form of chance of this
check of now says that they wish they'd
set up an oil fund
they should have done so alistair didn't
when he was chance of its Jekyll I say
when Scotland controls these resources
okay we should set up a fund for
Scotland so what is innovations